will be recorded you see the recording
in progress
so let me briefly introduce our speakers
i don't want to take too much of their
time
um and they'll present and there will
also be the usual time for
uh questions either typed into the chat
box or
people can unmute and and talk um
so um our first uh speaker
is dr rucci vanawala who
joined ohsu as an assistant professor of
surgery in the section of thoracic
surgery in the department of surgery
last year um another uh
person who i've talked to a lot but i
don't think we've actually ever
met in person due to the pandemic but
hopefully that'll change in the not too
distant future
um she's trained as a general surgeon
she did her
uh general surgery training at
university of massachusetts bay state
medical center
and then a fellowship in cardiothoracic
surgery at the university of iowa
and during her research time in her
residency and fellowship carried out
work in surgical education and
informatics and in fact she actually has
a master of science
in health informatics from northwestern
university
she will be joined in the talk by
her husband who she also collaborates
with professionally
uh dr jonathan jesneck and he is the cto
at the uh at a company called firefly
where he coordinates uh building of
hipaa compliant infrastructure
and analytics of surgical procedures and
procedural training
he um was a postdoctoral fellow at the
broad institute
of harvard and mit and dana farber
cancer institute at harvard medical
school
and developed an analysis system for
early stage discovery of pharmaceuticals
using gene expression
based high throughput screening he has a
phd in biomedical engineering
and also master's degrees in statistics
and computational biology and
bioinformatics all from duke university
so again
um they will uh present their talk and
hopefully leave a little bit of time for
questions and so um take it away
um dr fanawala okay well
thank you again for giving us a chance
to present
so as dr hirsch mentioned you know what
a lot of our work focuses on
is combining these data silos that exist
in surgical education
um sorry let me there we go uh
dr hirsch already kindly introduced us
um
i'm trained in surgery you know general
surgery cardiothoracic surgery most
importantly
i have not yet forgotten what it was
like to be a surgery resident
and to have your entire educational
experience very fragmented
um with information existing in the
electronic health record you have to log
your cases
you have to then get evaluations and
it's all piecemeal
and as a learner you're trying to bring
all of this together this problem exists
hundreds and thousands of fold for all
trainees
um i also have completed a fellowship in
surgical education so
jonathan and i working together um
decided that we would try to combine our
experience
research in um we're passionate about
innovation and invention
into the space of education informatics
which is a growing field
for disclosures um jonathan and i are
co-founders of firefly which is a
company that we started out of the
platform where
research originated and continues we own
intellectual property in the form of
patents
so training surgeons is hard
training doctors is complicated because
we
talk about how competency must exist
you know we must find a way to create
competent doctors who will go out into
practice
but what happens when we overlay
electronic health records with
handwritten evaluation tools
with um informal feedback that happens
verbally
and that isn't centralized anywhere so
when it goes back to actually retrieving
that information
it's very hard to and we're asking
humans
um in the form of residents you know
faculty
program directors to manually enter in
information
and we get always the broadening comment
of
doesn't that information exist somewhere
and it does
so by pulling and uniting a lot of this
information
we're trying to bring quantitative
analytics to the training of
surgeons and doctors and we'll go
through
so we have a lot of data to get through
but hopefully will be of interest
so our approach we decided that we would
um
tackle this project in a big way is
we would actually build a platform which
is what we have we have a live platform
in use
that we have um coded and developed
ourselves
so we started and our goal was to build
this foundational data bank
for surgical education research and at
the same time to provide
real-time solutions to the challenges
such as operative case logs
to provide context a resident and
surgeons must keep a log of all the
operations they do for credentialing for
a resident it's required for graduation
for faculty is required for your
maintenance of certification and your
board certification
operative and clinical evaluations
that's obvious to any person that's
trained in the medical
field that ongoing evaluations are
necessary to assess when a person is
ready to graduate
and the key thing is to identify
outliers
identify people who are struggling in
integrating everything together in a way
where we're able to
use the information create hypotheses
build solutions and have it all feedback
in the real time
in a key aspect of the design of this
databank
was a user interface that optimizes the
workflow for each participant
from resident and attending to program
director and residency coordinator
a lot of work has been done in this
space
where an intervention has been
interjected in the middle of the
workflow
that doesn't always make sense to
someone as in you know
you you've done this operation with a
resident and
like two weeks later you'll get an email
that you need to complete an evaluation
that's outside of the cognitive normal
workflow of that faculty member to do
the evaluation
understandably when you have something
that's not really directed to the
workflow compliance decreases
the validity and accuracy of the
information decreases
so what we did is really try to focus on
where
we could have the highest impact in the
workflow and limit the human interaction
at the critical points
and what we found is that when we
integrate all the siloed information
and the silo databases that we're
talking about are the operative
schedules from the electronic health
record
um the ac gme has a case logging
database
uh medhub which is used new innovations
contains a lot of the evaluative data on
the residents
and if we integrate them into one
platform as we've been able to do
the results are not just additive
they're actually more multiplicative
and what we're able to do is
when we have a very large database is
actually use a hype
throughput data mining analysis um
techniques
and generate hypotheses while
testing them almost and iterating on
them
as the process continues
so i'm sorry about that to kind of step
back
um you know we're talking about surgical
education
and we're talking about you know
aggregating a large amount of data
so we just like to talk about you know
big data hypothesis discovery surgical
education
in the context of the basic science
world such as cancer biology
so in these worlds we've moved away from
the very traditional linear pathway of
knowledge
discovery of gene identification which
you know traditionally had started out
with the genetic mapping and then on to
clinical implications
and what really revolutionized cancer
biology was technology
in the development of better tools and
the paradigm then became focused on dual
fronts
and what i mean by this is by having the
ability to test thousands of genes
instead of one gene
we were able to develop hypotheses
worthy of deeper analysis
and make the scientific process more
comprehensive efficient and iterative
and what we've done is actually applied
this concept to
surgical education and we're able to
identify large patterns
and questions that we were not yet able
to know
we were worthy of asking in solving
until we looked at the bigger picture
so what we did is
at the center census platform that we
have custom built
and it connects to the hospital from the
hospital we get the surgical schedule
it connects bi-directionally to the
attendings and the residents
it connects bi-directionally to
case-logging databases such as
ac gme the american college of surgery
surgeon-specific registry which is the
registry
that faculty members have to keep
mastery of breast surgery
and real-time analytics
so what have we discovered we've
discovered that the problem that we
sought out to fix
in our one institution actually is a
problem at many institutions
we started our platform in october 2016
and it was it really started out of
research because
we were really trying to solve a problem
that every single resident
and program director felt a pain for and
that existed everywhere so we've grown
to 23 institutions 15 departments nine
training programs
we have over 4 000 users and um about
450 surgical special
residents that are using it we've helped
log over 50 000 cases
in 10 000 evaluations and this is not to
pat us on the back
at all um this is more to
show how if we pay attention to the
workflow
and we unite data in a way we're able to
solve
big problems pretty quickly
so the surgical education landscape this
is some of the work what we've done
where we've amassed
this large amount of information and i
know some of this gets to be very niche
but if you'll just bear with me
i'll kind of you know i'll try to
contextualize it in a way that matters
um so when we're able to unite
anonymized data across institutions that
generally locked into
um if we would like to consider an
institution as a data silo which it
really is
uh and the case logs
that unification hasn't existed in a
centralized platform not only just
within an institution but across
institutions
we're able to look at things like this
genetic map
what this map looks at is what is the
variation
in the training experience from
institutions institution
and within a training program
specifically relevant to ohsu we're the
general surgery department
the residents may rotate at up to nine
different hospitals
we're trying to identify when a resident
becomes competent
we start to recognize that you know the
case mix they're exposed to
actually may have a significant impact
on
what is their maximum ability
to or what is what what does the
environment allow for their maximum
competency
if someone is at a low volume
institution for certain operation and
you have a new faculty member that
started there
that resident doesn't have the same
opportunity that another another
resident a high volume institution
with a senior faculty does but unless we
capture that information
overlay that on evaluation data how
would we know that
other than using our current what i
consider very archaic methods
of just basing it on the number of
operations a resident has done
and relying on their case logs means
that they're being
truthful in you know how much of the
operation they really did
but information exists that can help us
to better define how successful they can
really be
additionally as we're trying to do
studies to look at
you know how residents are performing
across institutions if we have
a profile and we can compare programs to
each other
we can actually support better
randomized controlled trials
with a better matching between programs
and then we can assess how does the
training profile change
potentially as teaching faculty change
other variables change
the interesting thing is is this
information exists
all we've done is connect segregated
information
and we can discover so many different
things
this is a plot this is a network plot
that we created
and what we did this off of is actually
looking at
information as simple as the operative
schedule pulled into the platform
so our schedules include the operation
that's being performed
and all the participants in it from
faculty members
to the residents that are participating
and what we did is we looked at
how often pairings happened between
faculty members and residents
the significance of this is that
senior residents are known to often
operate with senior surgeons because
you're trying to refine those
last bits of your skills before you
graduate junior residents usually get
assigned
to someone else because they usually
they don't have a lot of power in the
system
and you know we're trying to focus on
what their learning needs are at that
time
but if we identify these pairings that
may be happening in a way
that is not intentional instead and not
captured or understood or calculated
then does this actually have an
influence on how a resident's learning
so if you have a resident that is
struggling and they're working with an
attending that perhaps that
they just they don't work well together
or the resident is struggling to
understand
how to do an operation based on the
language that that attending is using
could we adjust the pairing by
identifying a faculty member
with which a resident learns at a
steeper rate
and assess how that happens unless we
look at how these
relationships actually already exist we
may not be able to capitalize on that
opportunity
so this is a system level you know view
of resident operative performance
and what we're looking at here is this
is pulling on the reference of the gene
expressions
and this is looking at the operative
evaluation data similar to a microarray
chip
with each column representing the
individual resident and each row
representing and attending
and what we're trying to do is to
identify patterns
of where a resident is getting more and
more autonomy
and does that match with certain
attendings are there certain pairings
are there certain attendings
that are very good at teaching and this
can be broken down to a specific
operation which is what we do
and this is useful for faculty
development again
this is information that exists we're
just applying a lot of data analytics
tools to make this
available invisible for use
this is another plot this is a heat map
that we've used for
operative skills um data across
institutions
and this is to identify cohorts of
residents and how they're performing
so are there certain characteristics of
residents that may be performing low
that actually follows a national trend
and can we actually create
interventions and remediation plans and
measure the effect
at a large scale can we identify why one
group
of residents is performing in a certain
way compared to their peers
at an institution and what if we share
this across institutions
we're able to do this when we free the
data from the confines of the silos
another thing that we're doing um and
this is this is getting into the
nitty-gritty
of surgery but from the informatics
level let's think about how we can reuse
components of information so operations
are done but operations really consist
of
bits and pieces so they're common
components
as in you know a simple simpler example
of a procedure is uh central line
placement
so there's ultrasound use um you know to
identify say you're putting in a
right-sided ij
central line we use the ultrasound to
identify the internal jugular artery
or vein similarly in the operating room
a resident would do that for a port
placement for chemotherapy
but instead of the current model where
we actually look at evaluating a
resident
on an operation what if we could break
down the components
we build a database that can support the
components and we actually start to map
over the crossover
between the components across operations
and now we actually start to build the
learning curves for the components
and then identify how they're
progressing in their learning of the
component
what we can do is start to map out at a
more granular level
how a resident is obtaining skill
and the concept of reusing information
is very
natural to us in in informatics
but it hasn't yet been done in surgical
education this is so this is actually
probably
one of the biggest spaces of our current
ongoing research
is to deconstruct um all the operations
that exist
in general surgery that are core
operations we've already done this in
cardiothoracic surgery
and the crossover and transferability of
components between
operations is tremendous and we're
hoping that over time as we get enough
cases we'll be able to
alter the paradigm of identifying
competency and operation to identifying
competency in case components
and constructing an operation from that
what was necessary for us to do this was
to build the infrastructure to support
that and we'll go through
our slides on that shortly
you know using these case components
we're able to break down
how a resident is performing compared to
their peers
at the institution and at the national
level
again by removing the confines of the
institution
residents generally aren't able to get
feedback on how they're comparing to
their peers
at a national level but it matters all
of a sudden when you're applying for
your fellowship positions
and you're applying for faculty
positions so having an awareness
of how you are learning compared to your
peers matters
additionally you know the phase that i'm
in where it's my transition to practice
as i finish fellowship
you know late last year and i'm starting
my faculty position
that knowing where i am on the learning
curve for case components
helps senior partners to know where they
may need to assist their junior partners
and this is all information this is just
finding a way for everyone to be able to
see it and use it
so this is actually now we're going to
move into the solution
that we've built the platform that we've
built and
um how we actually had to unite systems
that
don't want to talk and you know we're
talking about the stuff ehr the goal was
to not have to use interfaces and build
interfaces
and you know that's why a lot of these
languages were developed so we could
share information you know seamlessly
relatively seamlessly easier
than had been but the example of what we
had to do
is how interfaces are still important
to first identify as a proof of concept
that we have a problem and that we have
a solution
that can impact the problem and
hopefully over time
get these systems to connect to each
other instead of having to connect
through a platform
that we've built
so our platform sits at the center of
information that's shared from the
hospital in the form of a surgery
schedule
it sits you know with the system such as
medhub and new innovations for evals
and case reminders and then connects to
educational content um and then
lastly the case logs and we'll go
through each one of these segments and
how we actually
constructed our interfaces and the
impact we've seen
from our technology development
so the big picture and we always try to
keep this in mind
is our goal is freeing up
liberating the information connecting it
to the users
and having them utilize it having them
utilize it is more complicated than
the old concept of build it and they
will come that doesn't
really apply almost anywhere anymore
because
people have a lot of options so um the
author pip coburn in
i'm sorry i wrote 2016 in 2006 wrote
this book called the change function
some of you may know this
um what it is is the change function is
actually like
this functional calculation when you're
asking someone to do something new
something that's foreign to them
we have to have an assessment of what
their perceived benefit is
also what is their current pain and then
what is the perceived pain of adoption
and the key
word here is perceived there's a
perception
so the way in which we describe things
the way in which we present
information we ask for interaction is
very important and we've spent
a lot of time um trying to study and
understand the individual workflows of
all the different users
we were fortunate because i was a
resident i intimately understood the
workflow and the pain points for the
resident and for fellows
and we worked very closely with faculty
members and program directors to
understand their workflow
and then worked with surgical education
policy makers to understand
the big questions and we built
everything to hoping that we can make
things easier so people will participate
and we can get better information
so the or schedule is the first thing
that comes into the platform
using that a lot of the information's
already entered as in who's doing the
case
um which residents are participating uh
the date and the time of the operation
and that's the base information that
goes into the case log that's actually
been
up to this point manually entered by the
resident and we'll go through the
attrition that happens when you're
asking for someone to manually enter an
information that already exists
in another space then because we know
what
operations residents are doing we're
able to push evaluations to the faculty
members and the residents
which has increased the evaluation
completion because again
by asking faculty members to manually
enter in information
there's another degree of attrition that
happens and then the live
analytics that we're able to do because
we have worked on the statistical
modeling inbuilt into the platform to
share that information back
because people always want value added
to everything that they do
and we are data driven people surgical
residents our faculty
members are we like to see how we're
performing especially if we're
contributing to a system
and then when we know what people are
doing
what if we actually start to connect in
libraries of content
and that's one of the aspects of
research that we're working on
um and jonathan will go through some of
the mapping language that we're doing
for that
okay so with that high level overview
i'll uh
i'll talk about some interesting little
pieces of this about how we actually do
the data integration the data
transformation and standardization
and uh just as a small plug that we're
starting our research lab here
if this if any of this looks interesting
to any phd students or any faculty or
interested in collaborating uh we would
love to hear from you
okay uh so for this section i'll talk
about
um the was probably the simplest part of
the
system which is just sharing the surgery
schedule
from the hospital's ehr system into the
platform
but as you'll see even this small part
of who is doing what
procedure where gets complicated fast
so to to let you understand how this
works in the
in the real world of the resident
education
is that you have the cases assigned in
the ehr system
and there's usually depending on the how
the data is entered and where and who
has responsibilities for what there's
varying degrees of
trustworthiness in that data especially
with case assignments
and procedural details and then a lot of
times the residents have their own
flavor of that schedule either written
out with handwritten notes in their
notebook about what cases they've done
or maybe in a spreadsheet in their
laptop back home
and then we've tried to clean that up in
a schedule that we have in our system
that acts as a layer in between these
and then there's external case log
systems such as acgme case repository
that
the residents need to report their cases
to for graduation credit
so a lot of times this agrees somewhat
but not exactly with the other flavors
of the schedule
so we had to build a reconciling system
first of all just to get the base data
to work with
about how to know what cases actually
took place didn't get canceled didn't
get rescheduled
what what case assignments were
trustworthy you know and so with the
in order to account for uh add-on cases
and
last minute changes for if residents
were swapping in a case
and so we the the version that worked
best for this was basically to build
an inclusive uh kind of editable
platform so all the residents and the
staff could at any time make
quick corrections to it either during
the case or after a case
you know and and use this to make their
own uh
case assignments uh in order to to help
organize which residents we're going to
work on which case
in this way you can you can bring the uh
responsibility
of of the quality of the data to the
people who actually care about it most
and who need it for their own credit in
their own scheduling and education
purposes um
so this is a view of what it uh what it
looks like
on the computer screen uh the
the patient information has been
scrubbed out for this demo but
it's basically a flavor here of all the
the cases in here anybody can edit it
and change any information if you have
the right data permissions
and you see and you can change the
procedures as you get more information
you can click on staff or residence in
order to see
what level they're at and the details
and and make any quick changes there
and we just we built this as a way to uh
help put the power
back in the resident's hands so that
they could use it uh in order to make
their own lives easier
okay and so um as uh richie was
mentioning with the change function
kind of the magic formula that we happen
upon by trial and error is
if you're asking for a minute of a
really busy person's time
you have to figure out how to save them
two minutes elsewhere
and so what we try to do to encourage
more participation is
every time we have a form anywhere try
to make it smaller
so that you have appropriate suggestions
automatically appearing
and help auto fill out the form as much
as possible with the confirmation at the
end so that the
information is correct so here for
example two small
two small pieces that you can see is if
you're adding a case or editing it based
on
what kind of case it is the the
appropriate residents and staff members
suggestions show up there so you could
just uh
you can agree to the suggestions or do a
new search and change it if something
unexpected is happening
and the same thing with the type of
procedures
okay um and then what i'll talk about is
another kind of interesting
quick uh informatics aside is that as
you can imagine
just using a designed data api
is a big enough project you know if
there's an hl7 data feed or a fire data
feed
but uh for these kind of
multi-institutional projects
uh most of the time we don't have that
luxury you have to get more flexible
about how you accept input data and so a
lot of
times our the data that we need to
integrate are
old printouts or even handwritten notes
um and from
all sorts of various silos that we're
always surprised to find out exist here
and there across computers
in in filing cabinets so for example we
have to uh
use some some image processing in order
to just get some of these printed data
standardized and inputted so here's an
example of
having a low resolution text that we use
some image processing algorithms on to
clean up the characters
and then use a convolutional neural
network uh to do optical character
recognition to figure out what letters
and what words those actually are
before we can import into a digital
format
additionally there's all sorts of other
interesting image processing
work that needs to be done up front such
as removing artifacts
from from various forms that don't
contribute anything to the information
uh lines and and other parts of the form
and also there are even screenshots that
need to be assembled sometimes even from
uh
resident holding up a phone if there's
really no other way to get the data that
they need to integrate
so taking all those partial screenshots
doing automated
panorama stitching and and repositioning
to
to piece all those together like a big
puzzle and then do the full
the optical character recognition on
that form
so this is kind of a the the unsexy part
of the data integration but
it's it's really allowed a lot of these
projects to come together faster than a
official api can be built for them
okay then case logging all right
um so now that we have the operative
schedule that's imported into the
platform you know the residents can use
it is
going into the case logging so for the
case logging
we're trying to connect to the ac gme
american college of surgery
and the mastery of breast surgery
so case logging is always has always
been a problem
for residents because residents tend to
keep a record you know a notebook
sticker somewhere a bag of stickers i'm
not kidding um excel spreadsheets and
they lose that information
but that information is actually the
base information for the policies we
make
on how many cases are needed for
graduation so the accuracy of that
and having attrition in lost cases has
significant impact
when we talk to the residents and even
from when i was a resident in
understanding the workflow
the main issue was is that in acgme you
have to manually enter in
all the information again but you're
like well the schedule
the information exists in the ehr why
can i not get it over
and it's such a simple conceptual
problem
fraught with a lot of like real life
issue of you know
the hospital it's hard to get a live
feed of the data
you know apis don't exist on both sides
um
hospitals are very protective over that
information so we're depending on
residents
so to log that information so we decided
that we would um find a way to build an
interface you know working with a
hospital being
creating this hipaa compliant platform
that actually pulls in the operative
information and puts it into the form
and asks the resident to only work on
the cpt code
so what we have to do because apis don't
exist between ac
you know for acgme american college of
surgery or mastery of breast surgery any
of
these
is actually construct our own pseudo
apis
that connect the platform to those to
allow for the information logging
um what this highlights is that
in in medicine and surgery and
especially in surgical education
we have not advanced as far as some of
the other fields have with apis for data
sharing
and it has a bigger impact than we
probably recognize
and um what we're learning in measuring
is actually the scale of the impact
and why we're hoping over time that
these databases and organizations will
open up apis to make
information sharing more seamless
between the hospital
and their databases so an example of
what we've discovered
because we have we've helped residents
log
over 50 000 cases is the scale of the
problem
we just submitted this to the american
college of surgery so
um it's kind of it's new data is
we have residents that do their case
assignments within the platform
we know what cases the residents are
logging
so we've actually been able to show that
based on two
truth-based you know databases 30
of cases go unlocked so a third of cases
are unaccounted for
that is a huge impact on what our
understanding is
of what residents are actually doing in
the operating room and how they're
training
by having the information pulled in so
they don't have to enter it
we weren't able to decrease it down to
zero but it was down to ten percent so
there's still
a portion of it that we can't fix or
reconcile because that's probably a
behavior a human behavior part of it
but 20 of it is a workflow issue
of data reentry redundant um
work on the side of the user in really a
failing on our part of not reusing
existing data because of the limitations
by siloing information
by making the information already exists
there
surgeons are able to log their cases you
know in 10 seconds
or so so by improving the workflow down
to
when you know 10 seconds to log a case
we can get people to log more cases
which means they're more likely
to log the cases instead of having these
very fragmented experiences and
you know if it takes you two minutes to
log a case you're not likely to go
through 50 cases and log them
but if it takes you 10 seconds you'll
log more of them
and this is just it's the fact that we
really wanted to understand the workflow
and what the hiccups are and to build to
that
most of them log the same day because it
fits in
at the end of doing the case um because
you're sitting at the computer or you
know you're on your phone or something
and you get an alert like oh did you do
a case
and you're able to log it importantly
we're able to help residents log their
cases this is data that we had presented
at the american college of surgery
um and the the lag between
when they do the operation and when they
log it is reduced down to you know
two to three days compared to previously
in like a week or up to 17 days
and sometimes but the residents are
really bad at logging it would go up to
80 days
and you can understand that you know at
80 days
those people probably have lost a lot of
their cases
and then this is very interesting
because this is where we're looking at
the
we're trying to stratify the behavior of
the people who are
logging their cases so you know if
they're logging directly into ac gme
where they have to manually type in all
the information
it was almost a 50 50 split early
loggers and late loggers early loggers
log within 70 days late loggers log
after 70 days
but by pulling in that information of
the operative schedule without
them having to enter it we're able to
convert 20 percent of late loggers
into early loggers those are the people
who benefit
from freeing up data and integrating it
what we just submitted in a manuscript
is actually looking at
um how many cases residents log a week
and this was done across
three institutions so when residents
have to log you know mainly
enter in their information into ac gme
they log about one and a half cases a
week
when we had our platform as an
intervention
where we pulled in the operative
schedule and we used our machine
learning driven cpt code
search they logged four and a half cases
a week
and then we actually did a test
intervention where we
didn't enter in the operative schedule
we just had the you know functional
electronic smart electronic notebook
with a smart cpt search
just to see what is the impact the true
impact of entering data um from the
operative schedule
and the case logging dropped using the
platform residents preferred to just use
ac gme because they have to manually and
enter in the information anyways
and then when we resumed it it returned
back to the same level
so it's sustained what we know is having
to enter in redundant information
leads to problems residents just don't
log cases and they don't go anywhere
else they don't go into acgme either
because we didn't see a
symmetric increase in the ac gme direct
case login
and then um by understanding
what cases residents are doing by using
their case logs
we have built out markov models to
predict
how many cases a resident will do you
know before the covid
19 pandemic this was more of an esoteric
research thing for us because we're very
interested in understanding how can we
change how many
of a certain type of operation residents
are doing but this is becoming more
relevant
because there was a decrease in the
number of elective cases
and the american board of surgery
actually
just a few weeks ago put out a hardship
policy allowing residents who have done
20 less cases
for graduation but this this will become
relevant
when we're trying to understand you know
these junior residents they're going to
be ready to graduate
how many cases can we predict that
they'll be doing
if we continue on the same sort of up
and down trend of you know having
elective cases started and having them
go down and go back and forth
so the next phase that we're looking at
um are
is the evaluations so
if you kind of think back to that slide
and i'm sorry i didn't put it in there
like the sandwich of all the layers and
how we're reusing information
kind of just to recap from the beginning
oh our schedule is in there
that's the base information for case
logging that includes
what operation a resident did with their
faculty member
so we want people to do evaluations at
the end of the operation
we just built something and we thought
like okay what if we just push a
reminder to the faculty members
we automate that process can we get more
evaluations completed
because evaluations to provide some
background
a resident tends to get probably about
10 operative evaluations a year
they do about 200 to 300
if not more operations a year so they
get barely any operative evaluations
so this is a big problem but we need to
know how they're training
so we wanted to see what happens if you
just push a reminder because we have the
information
we embedded um multiple types of
evaluations
and in in surgery there are evaluations
that are specific to an operation their
evaluation is
just general evaluations and
as we're always looking to like you know
we don't want to frustrate the faculty
members because we want them to do these
evaluations we know that
they tend to not like to do them because
it's more time is we cannot
have the wrong evaluation show up for
the wrong operation
so we actually built in our own mapping
that exists between
the description of the evaluations and
the human readable description
of an operation and that's actually more
variable than you would anticipate
so for a laparoscopic cholecystectomy
there are approximately 15 ways in which
that's booked and described
as people um schedule an operation
so we built this very complex mapping
that we had to create on our own
to allow the right evaluations to show
up for the right operations in an
automated fashion
this is the evaluation life cycle so we
estimated you know five o'clock
generally people are done with their um
cases that the platform an automated way
will send out a reminder
the attending can get it on their phone
um in their email they just have to
click a link because again
we want to we want to make this easy for
them to do
and they quickly submit this email
um that information is automatically
pushed to the resident
because residents want to know how
they're performing and they want their
feedback
quickly um it goes into the attendings
profile and then it goes to the program
director also
so by having that automated push having
it immediately available
is the value added for the residents and
for the
attendings and the program directors and
again we want people
to keep sharing that information we want
to keep gathering information on how
we're training residents
so it's important we understand what
motivates them to keep participating
and what we're able to do is um build
out bayesian directed learning curves
so this is another um aspect of our
research
is actually identifying where someone is
on the learning curve now to build
learning curves you can't do that off of
10 evaluations that are not specific to
an operation
we have to do that we need multiple
evaluations for a certain type of
operation
we're able to identify where a resident
is on their learning curve
most learning curves are sigmoidal
in a resident that's at the steep part
of the learning curve where they're just
starting to get it
having this information can help a
program director
or a chief resident who's assigning the
cases to know that you know what ruchi
would benefit from doing five more of
these operations
because then she may reach that
asymptotic phase of learning
where we won't have this skill decrement
that she will have truly achieved
competency
but unless we map this information out
our current way of doing this
is by gestalt by the faculty member
saying you know what i think she's
starting to get it you know
see if you can do a couple of cases with
me or based on case numbers
but again if the case numbers aren't
accurate how do we know
we've just been kind of making it up
honestly
we're able to find is by having this
workflow directed you know automated
push of the evaluations
um faculty members you know could do
them pretty quickly
and they usually did them right after
the operation compared to if they were
going to get an
email reminder from another system like
medhub
and that was we we think that's because
they have to
log into another platform that does
that's purely for evaluations
by having a one-stop shop gets people to
do more
things by reusing the information
this is information um data that we had
presented
uh two years ago in that
the lag time for getting the evaluations
when it was in a centralized platform
was like a day compared to 36 days
um plus or minus or you know really plus
30 days
sorry i'll pass it back to jonathan for
targeted okay
thank you so um these these learning
curves that rishi was describing are
really interesting
for lots of reasons one of the things
that we're thinking about is
helping to give to give
very measurable actionable tools to the
program director to try
different things to see what helps their
residents learn better and learn faster
and fewer cases and how to optimize
the case assignments and learning
experience so one of those
one of those main innovation tactics
is targeted education so the idea here
is that
we're trying to make it much easier
lower the
the energy barrier for a resident to
read up on a case
and to prepare for a case because uh
just most of the time
that after a very busy day in the
hospital they come home
wiped they just want to crash and it's
very difficult to actually get into that
study self-improvement mindset to to
start working
to start preparing for cases and it's
especially difficult during the day in
the hospital when there's a million
demands on your time
so we were thinking if we could help
push
the right content in a nice concise
manner to the right people the right
time
hopefully we would see the shape of the
learning curve change so that the
residents could actually learn
faster on fewer cases and that would
help them achieve a greater level of
competency
so this is an active area of research
right now that that we're just starting
okay so the easiest way we could think
of as pushing it to the residence
phones as recommendations and also just
having an easy click right from the
schedule
so if you're a resident let's say you
have a laptop
all you need to do is click on it and
you can see a video showing the
technique or maybe a
anatomical diagram illustrations so you
can
remember the relevant parts of the
anatomy or maybe a textbook chapter if
you need to dive in if you have
if you have a few more minutes before
your case to review okay
so to do that as you can imagine there's
a lot of
background data organization work that
you need to
not only know what educational content
are available but
how what uh how relevant each one is to
each kind of procedure and
and what is appropriate for which
resident for which case
so we're doing this in a two-prong
manner uh a manual
in a semi-automated way manual way as uh
luckily
a lot of the teaching faculty and and
even some residents are
have already assembled a very high
quality
bank of papers their favorite papers
that they like to read or at least their
favorite
textbooks so we've gone through and
we're working with them to help
get a curated list of the content i
think is the most helpful for each case
type
if then in parallel to that we're
looking at a semi-automated way
to crawl through relevant journals and
relevant uh textbooks
to piece out the uh the important pieces
of educational content so that we can
start tagging them and having them
available for recommendations
so here you can see it's looking at
different pieces of a journal article
and now we need to figure out what each
piece is
sounds like we may have one of our usual
internet hiccups are
other people able to hear me
yes yes we can hear you okay well
hopefully um
hopefully they'll come back
give it
give it a minute or so
dr hirsch is there anywhere to ask him
if one of them can log in on their phone
uh um yeah we can for audio purposes
only
yeah let me um i'll send a message
um
oh
are you guys at ohsu yeah yeah
oh really yes you know the university is
supposed to have such great bandwidth um
anyways we we we lost you about a minute
ago
maybe okay a little bit of that um
i don't know how much uh how much more
you have to go and we're at the last
slide
okay okay good because i think probably
uh people want to ask some
questions yes sure um where did our
presentation go just try it yeah
it's
it's the other that's no it's not that
okay
okay sorry um
we closed everything out because we
didn't know if it was
us
okay thank you sorry about that
okay um maybe we could just wrap it up
and ask
questions too yeah i think we are pretty
much at the end
sorry so anyway um i guess just to give
a quick recap of that we're
we're we're using these models to try to
figure out
which content to push to the resident at
the right time and then we're measuring
whether they learn faster by reading the
material
and then sorry last 30 seconds in
closing um
training residence is hard reusing
information
has a huge impact um paying attention to
workflow
is very important and um
with a large scale system you know we
can kind of find questions and solve
them or try to work on solving them
entering our solutions at the same time
and surgical education can be more of a
data science maybe more
nerdy than most surgeons would want but
can be if
thank you yeah well that's great um
um i just want to make a comment and
then ask a quick question and um
being someone from an internal medicine
background i won't
drag out my surgeon jokes about data and
knowledge
but um i i have actually come to learn
actually that surgeons are actually very
data driven
um i you know i think you demonstrate
some cardinal principles of informatics
that you know if you
um make things easy for people to put
data in
and if you provide them usefulness
when you get the data out you you um you
get a more engaged audience i think
that's true with everything related to
data
and healthcare and medicine um i i'm
curious um
i i don't want to take all the question
time but what you see as kind of the
major
research questions that you want to
answer going forward
and i think you're might be here yeah um
one of the biggest is uh the learning
curves
is actually using the case components
and identifying commonality
across operations in
identifying um how we can train people
better
by figuring out how components match
across operations
that's probably that's one of the
biggest and i think that's actually
um there's a lot of work that's
happening in that and it will really
change how we think about
competency-based education and i don't
think it's possible to actually do that
without
informatics and data science driving it
because the information becomes too
granular
and too hard to manage by a single
person which is why i think we haven't
achieved it at this point
great there's a question and
comment in the chat box um
from um eric eric wecker one of our
clinical informatics fellows
yes who was a bad lager in his residency
see everyone knows it uh okay
let's see i'll just read this in my
residency i qualified as one of the bad
loggers family medicine residency
uh my qi project for residency was to
generate a report from hospital ehrm
process in such a way that was
suitable to use for acgme and make this
reusable for other residents he
accomplishes goal
uh required periodic running of report
processing with the excel spreadsheet
um small amount of time we wish i had
more so yeah i think
it's you know it's a problem as eric
points out that exists for everyone
and you know one of the big things is
is that it's hard for hospitals to share
the information i mean really it takes
us
months to a year you know to establish
that relationship because
it doesn't necessarily exist but
educational informatics um especially in
medical and surgical education i think
is a
under research under um
resourced area but has a lot of impact
on
how we train physicians
great any other questions or comments
i see someone waving you want to unmute
and ask
yeah dr heard so full disclosure i'm a
nurse practitioner that works
um under dr thana wallace she's my boss
so i i've got a bias
um dr athena wallace jonathan thank you
so much
i'm grateful for this and i'm very
grateful that you both are
at ohsu two particular questions
on many of the slides you would identify
or you had mentioned
that the relationship between a platform
and for example acgme and the acs
is bi-directional but the arrows were
only going one direction so d
um does the acgme have access to the
platform in order to
just evaluate or even in rare
circumstances
manipulate that they access it second
question
um not sort of kind of sort of related
um there was a slide later in the
presentation that showed two pie graphs
and you showed
uh the the relationship between late
loggers
and early loggers and you had mentioned
that you set the time
for early loggers as 70 days
so yeah supposed to be seven sorry sorry
okay okay seven days okay thank you
that answers that question so um just
the first question
yes um so the bi-directionality is
actually
um not in that acgme you know uh
can interrogate the data within the
platform it's more that
um we reconcile the information so
there's a possibility
of you know the classic database error
of
not having a unifying key between a
common key between
you know two so if a resident uses the
platform to log the case and then they
go into ac gme and they erroneously log
the case
we are able to bi-directionally you know
query that information and correct for
it to reconcile so that's more the
bi-directionality of it
well great we're um we're just about at
the hour
um uh i enjoyed your presentation i'm
sure uh
others others did as well and um like
you said at the beginning if
any um students or fellows have an
interest in this kind of work
they should reach out to you and
see what opportunities uh may exist
so good um thank you for presenting and
um we'll look forward to
seeing you around campus at some point
and um i will um i'll be seeing the
fellows
shortly um in in their meeting